et si je te disais que je veux être écrivain
oh on y va
Mira n'a aucun moyen de trouver un mari je
ne vais pas me marier pas maintenant pas toujours
bien c'est clair alors
Wordsworth Shelly eh bien ces romantiques
ne sont pas bons pour toi
n'  ne vous inquiétez pas un peu d'emphase
vous devez écrire vraiment personne ne m'a jamais dit
ça avant que
nous appartenions ensemble
mes trois mousquetaires et moi
je viens d'entendre que j'aurais pu vitrer les
bagages que nous sommes nés pour faire une marque dans le
monde
Edward pilote a l'air frère soudainement si
adulte
il n'a que 80 ans les rapports dans la ville
qui se sont déjà inscrits à quoi cela ressemblera-t-il
de ne pas être parmi eux auxquels vous
vous êtes inscrit
et les générations ont la chance de
s'impliquer dans quelque chose comme ça
je reviens
il y a un appel aux volontaires c'est  aussi
proche de lui que possible je rencontre soit
notre génération ne sera plus jamais nouvelle
notre jeunesse nous a été volée ce
pot détruit il pourrait être parti la
vie l'amour et tu
penses que ce qu'ils ont signifié pour moi
je ne t'abandonnerai pas
est  ma promesse pour toi
Vous êtes tous d'
accord sur la guerre des hommes
Oh